[Music]
you offered to do a nude layout if the
money was right well I said I was mad
because not one meant the magazine has
approached me do a nude layout never and
I thought that angers me it angered you
and so you know I'm seeing what people
say mostly and so then that day they
start coming in there go well you know I
lived in my mom's basement and I'd love
to shoot you in this mess that's not the
point
I'm charging 1 million that was 1
million dollars so that you know it's
not just to do free nudes for crying out
loud the big day for the news yeah white
for free for crisis yeah yeah start that
negotiation yeah yeah oh there's no
buyers yeah Wow yeah wait a minute
that's gonna change after tonight's
appearance that'll change yeah now you
have said good I had lipo not long ago
you had lipo yeah I did I got my stomach
live boned
oh you live it you look fantastic
the only area that they lipo or they
also lipo other areas as well and where
ever you know where you going make you
know you tell the doctor where you're
wanting it next right okay so you had
the stomach light I had my stomach I
bought and put in my butt
they took those they took the the fat
out of the stomach they put it in your
butt yeah why did you want it in your
butt because I wanted to have a but I've
never had a butt my whole life I've just
basically been asked us in an ass based
economy always wanted to have a round
but like all the girls have these days
you know I wanted to I sympathize
because I have no butt whatsoever abs
it's just a straight drop to my ankles
there's nothing there and I've always
thought like maybe I should think about
getting some fat injected into my butt
give me a self a nice round bottom
that's what I thought you know people
said well Roseanne you know it because
I'm like look at the Kardashians you
know they you know especially the OJ's
daughter one they have no
I don't know if that's been they have
she asked like such a big and so I asked
my friend you know and they said well
you can get butt implants if you really
want but I thought well I I'd never get
anything and planned it into my butt
yeah except for that one time it was
college no I
they sucked it out and put it in my butt
now I have like kind of a bump in my
butt now I'm very thrilled yeah well
congratulations so that's exciting
you